joining me now is Victor Davis Hansen
senior fellow at the Hoover institution
Victor um America is is obviously being
played because we're weak economically
and and culturally and to that point a
poll earlier this summer found that only
about 18% of people ages 18 to 34 now
say they're extremely proud or proud to
be an American back in 2013 that figure
was
85% is there going to be a rally around
the flag moment with this situation and
this culture
Victor
no because young people see all the
advantages in being anti-American that
that's the culture at College that's the
culture in the media and they feel that
they adapt it adapt to it rather than
reject it and be patriotic then they'll
benefit and you know you mentioned
deterence you can't achieve deterrence
by talking loudly and frequently and
carrying a twig it's only seldomly and
quietly with a club so if you want
Hezbollah to enter and Iran to enter
this fry then you will restrict Israel
and you'll tell the world that Israel
even the most unimaginable crime of
butchering a thousand Jews has no
consequences or you'll be Anthony
blinkin and on a fake story about an
Israeli attack on a hospital you order
or suggest that embassies in the Middle
East will lower their flags half half
mask or give Iran 6 billion or give
Hamas basically another 100 million
after restoring a in general to the
Palestinian all of that will encourage
Hezbollah and Iran to go in on the
premise that look at these westerners
and Israel they even when we do this
thing to them the unimaginable the
subhuman say still won't react and they
they'll be encouraged to do something
stupid and you're right about deterrence
Laura it's multifaceted economic it's
your border it's National unity and when
you start to lose that and you compound
it with a military short of recruits a
politicized military Afghanistan the
Chinese balloon uh Biden saying he
wouldn't react in Ukraine if it was a
minor offenseive that's all Force
multiplying each other and then we get
some a dangerous situation where Iran
and Hezbollah will do something stupid
because even at our ner we have the
power to destroy both so we don't want
to do that but they may miscalculate and
think otherwise given our current state
and that's very dangerous and it's
counterintuitive I know but you want
peace let the isra let the Israelis take
care of Hamas well Victor that is the
concern China is sending um power to the
region obviously we have a presence
there Iran is clearly it looks like on
the move so the opportunity for a
mistake to cause a major uh world
changing event in the Middle East is
real and I'm sorry given what they did
in Afghanistan given what they're doing
to our recruits and to our are in in our
faith in the system I I don't I frankly
don't have a lot of you know faith in
them I really
don't you're absolutely right because
you see what China is trying to do it
sees a vacuum of leadership and power
and it wants to replay the role of the
Soviet Union in the Cold War it thinks
we're going to be the patron and we're
going to have all these clients that
contest the allies of the United States
and indeed the United States itself and
then they'll think that they can rely on
our power to the United States and get a
free hand that's why it's very important
to stand up to China and say you're not
going to be the patron of these
murderous Thugs and yet China's got the
opposite uh impression because of our
appeasement and mfic and it's it's the
11th hour we can still restore deter but
we have to make a radical shift in our
political leadership well Karen John
Pier was asked an important question
about the wars around the world watch
this why aren't we doing a better job
from preventing these wars in the first
place our uh goal has always been a
prosperous Middle East a peaceful Middle
East make sure that we we bring our
allies and uh Partners together that
doesn't stop but at the same time right
if Russia's going to invade invade
Ukraine we have to be there for Ukraine
well that's an excellent question Victor
they were supposed to be the adults in
charge the force of Sanity Trump was
going to blow up the world and now look
at the
world they don't understand human nature
when you're unpredictable and you're
scary that's civilized when you're
predictably weak that's uncivilized the
the former stops Wars the latter invites
it and that's what they're doing they're
so self-righteous and they think they
have such a superior morality they don't
understand they're really abjectly aoral
especially when they pressure Israel not
to strike back at Hamas Israel needs to
do that for moral reasons and to
instruct the Middle East the wages of
Terror and murder and Butchery well now
it looks like Hamas gets to buy some
time by playing the good guy and
releasing these these hostages I I mean
it's you can't make this out Victor
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else